[Music]
we can build really big things in space
okay not that big yet but we've packed
the Earth's lower orbit with about 5,000
satellites some still functioning and
some not what if we could build a bigger
brighter satellite and put it into
Earth's lower orbit something that would
reflect so much sunlight that we'd never
have to turn our lights on again I'm
talking about an artificial moon how big
could we possibly make it and why would
it be a bad idea to proceed with this
space construction project this is what
if and here's what would happen if we
created an artificial moon the largest
satellite we've put into lower orbit the
International Space Station is as long
as a football field we assembled it in
pieces in several launches and now it's
revolving around the earth some 400
kilometers above us how would we launch
an artificial moon that's ten times
bigger than that and position it high
above the Earth's surface
most of the Earth's satellites in low
orbit are operating just above the ISS
some of them are parked in geostationary
orbit about 35,000 kilometers above the
earth's equator the real moon revolves
around us from a distance of 380,000
kilometers away
but we don't need to put our artificial
moon that far away we place it somewhere
between the earth and the ISS that's a
good spot right there we'd have to make
sure it maintains a speed of twenty
seven thousand four hundred kilometers
per hour otherwise it falls back to
earth we'd cover its surface with some
highly reflective material so that it
could bounce the light from the Sun back
at us then we turn off our lights and
enjoy bright nights all year long if
you're not into falling asleep with the
lights on you'd need to get some very
dark blinds for your bedroom too bad
animals wouldn't have the same option
this new moon might cause havoc for
nocturnal creatures who rely on
moonlight to mate hunt or navigate too
much light at night could mess around
with your body - leading to obesity and
a higher chance of heart disease
diabetes and depression the artificial
moon would also obscure the view of the
natural sky ground-based telescopes
wouldn't be able to capture images of
deep space it could result in us giving
up on our dreams to go to distant stars
imprisoning us on earth forever
so think about it do we really want this
second moon well wait for it some
sources have reported that Chinese space
engineers are already working on it
their moon would be not just ten but
eighty times bigger than the ISS it
would shine eight times brighter than
the natural moon and it would supposedly
save them 173 million dollars a year in
electricity bills
however we haven't seen the actual plans
or a development strategy so don't be
upset if an artificial moon doesn't
appear in the sky sometime soon we still
like our natural beautiful moon that we
could colonize and use as a cosmic
airport for future space travel but
that's a story for another what if
[Music]